this is it's always when people say I'm
not really into deposit it doesn't
matter you don't get to choose you don't
get to choose you don't get to bow out
and say well I you know it's not my
thing so you just don't vote guess what
there still is someone making these
decisions yeah yeah it just happens to
not be you what you're doing is you're
putting your fate in the hands of
somebody else okay let's get to your
layers advice is needed all right hey
this one me here you love your content
my man I think you meant to say love
your content my guru button yeah I'll
let us close I have one question for you
I'm only 21 and I honestly don't care
about politics at all is that a bad
thing in the long run appreciate the
time I don't need to appreciate it that
much this was a very short letter and we
won't give you much time you know I was
fed up funny people says I don't care
about politics for me and I don't want
to talk about religion in politics and
that's not really my thing
I don't really it's it's not interesting
to me I don't care about it let me ask
you this do you not care about being
able to speak freely without fear of
retribution from an authoritarian
government do you not care about your
god-given right to self-preservation the
ability to defend you and yours yeah
do you not care about the world that
you're chill your potential future
children could be living it out I mean
that in like the gay green sense I mean
like actually in the sense of the state
of the country and their god-given
freedoms and rights and if those are
maintained do you not care about those
things those things don't affect you at
all this is it's always when people say
I'm not really in college it doesn't
matter you don't get to choose you don't
get to choose you don't get to bow out
and say well I you know it's not my
thing so you just don't vote guess what
there still is someone making these
decisions yeah yeah it just happens to
not be you what you're doing is you're
putting your fate in the hands of
somebody else and if you've gone your
entire life and never thought about the
issues of what's your opinion on murder
have you ever pondered the idea of what
constitutes murder right these things
should matter to everyone who is a human
being and cares about the world that
they live in and that being said
unfortunately today you have people in
someone considers an ivory tower some
call it the swamp we're making these
decisions that affect everyday Americans
it's often very ignorant where you have
people say well I don't know why people
make such a big deal I would they ever
never done anything that's affected me
that's not true they do things that
affect you and something you know this
is something else too
but as important if you're emailing the
show I assume you have some kind of an
interest and maybe a more of a cultural
interest in finical interest but young
people tend to either
they tend to break off into two groups
which is why it's so it's so inspiring
to see so many people who are sort of
doing the column read pilled people who
are a conservative sort of
anti-authoritarian you're seeing this
this spread quite a bit it didn't exist
when I started on YouTube in 2009 but
typically and this was for a very long
time with young people as it relates to
voting you have people who are either a
disinterested like yourself and the
people who are proactive the people who
actually do engage in vote do so very
selfishly and what really bothers me is
there's this myth people I think falsely
attributed that quote to Churchill if
I'm not mistaken it might've been like a
French philosopher I I don't know
exactly where it originates but the
quote if you were you know if you're
when you're young it's something like if
you're young and you're not a liberal
you have no heart if you're older and
you're not a conservative you have no
brain that's attributed to chill and a
meme it's not actually Churchill who
coined that phrase I disagree with that
I really disagree with that it's also I
have a problem with this idea of
compassionate conservatism that people
say well hold on a second compassionate
conservatism the idea that conservatives
aren't compassionate that they don't
have a heart let me ask you this who do
you think lives more selfishly what
we're talking about why people are
voting who has pure motives in their
heart who lives more selfishly the
22-year old college student or the
40-year old dad of four well missus who
and your experience on your day to day
lives is a more selfish person who has
to think of others before their own
needs the 26 year old young professional
woman who works at a marketing firm in
New York City or a stay-at-home mom
who's 35 years old a mess keep track of
the bills who do you think in your
estimation wakes up every day and has to
esteem somebody else first has to put
someone else's needs above their own
people do become more conservative as
they get older that is absolutely true
but it's not because it become more
selfish people say it's because they
accrued net worth well sure they do but
they aren't billionaires these aren't
people who are voting for lower taxes
because every single person who's over
the age of 45 is a billionaire what does
happen is people become more
conservative as they get older because
they don't have the luxury of living
selfishly that's what bothers mean it
bothers me when conservatives concede
that ground and it bothers me when
people who consider themselves
apolitical say I'm not going to engage
because it really affects me that now
yeah it does and you've got some Bernie
bro down there who's getting a degree in
Gender Studies who's contributing
nothing to the world who is engaging
under the
of wanting to help the downtrodden
because he wants us to agree to cost him
a whopping $0 yeah why do you think it
is that college students want free
everything and then adults young and
even young adults by the way if you look
at young adults who have kids who are
made they also tend to be more
conservative because they have to worry
about people other than themselves and
they understand that Washington DC
allocating that money to litter the
cause du jour is is not going to help
other people as much as this person can
providing for their family tired of that
myth the idea that conservatives are
selfish and liberals are inherently more
generous really they're spending
somebody else's money look at people and
what they do with their own money and
look at how they live you tell me that
you believe the church-going 45 year old
father of four is more selfish than the
college student the low information
voting bloc who goes for the DNC because
guess what if you don't vote you're
handing that baton over to them and
giving them complete control
hey there YouTube viewer if you like
this video click one of these other
videos playing in a box subscribe hit
the notification bell you may be
wondering why after this outlandish
video this is such a straight end card
that's because we've recently learned
that end cards actually determine the
YouTube algorithm as it relates to
controversy on a sliding scale so we
have a yellow and it escalates all the
way to the word